>> ♪ ♪
>> NEW DEVELOPMENTS IN THE
JUSSIE SMOLLETT CASE.
CHICAGO POLICE RELEASED HUNDREDS
OF DOCUMENT ABOUT THE ALLEGED
HATE CRIME HOAX.
PROSECUTORS TOLD DETECTIVES THEY
WERE WORKING ON A PLEA DEAL A
MONTH BEFORE ALL 16 FELONY COUNT
WERE SUDDENLY DROPPED.
SMOLLETT DENIED TO POLICE THAT
THE BROTHERS LINKED TO THE CASE
WERE HIS ATTACKERS CITING THEIR
START SKIN COLOR.
HE SAID HIS ATTACKERS WERE
WHITE.
SMOLLETT ASKED THE BROTHERS IN A
TEXT MESSAGE.
THIS IS NOT GOING AWAY.
THIS IS VERY BAD NEWS FOR KIM
FOX THE PROSECUTOR WHO DROPPED
THIS CASE TO EVERYONE'S SHOCK.
GREG, THIS IS VERY INTERESTING
TO ME.
THAT THIS IS LIKE PEOPLE HAVE
DUG THEIR TEETH IN.
IT'S VERY GOOD NEWS FOR EQUAL
JUSTICE.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT IT IS?
I THINK THEY UNDER-ESTIMATED THE
MAGNITUDE OF THE HOAX.
THEY LOOKED AT PAST HOAXES AND
THE MEDIA WILL COVER THE
INCIDENT.
BUT WHEN THE INCIDENT UNRAVELS
THEY MOVE ON.
BECAUSE IT WAS A NATIONAL STORY
BECAUSE OF THE MAGA HATS AND THE
TRUMP RELATIONSHIP, IT MADE
HIDING THIS IMPOSSIBLE.
THEY WERE TRYING TO DO HIM A
FAVOR AND SWEEP IT UNDER THE
RUG.
BUT HE COULD NOT KEEP HIS MOUTH
SHUT AND SCREWED HIMSELF.
I SAID THIS BEFORE -- HE CAN
RESURRECT HIS CAREER AND MAKE
HIS LIFE BETTER TO COME CLEAN
AND ACTUALLY DIRECTLY APPEAL TO
THE PEOPLE THAT HE DEMONIZED.
THERE IS A POTENTIAL, AMONG
REPUBLICANS AND CONSERVATIVE AND
THE RELIGIOUS, DON'T
UNDER-ESTIMATE THE AMOUNT OF
FORGIVENESS OUT THERE.
IF HE SAID, LOOK, I WRONGLY
SMEARED TRUMP -- THAT WOULD BE
SOMETHING I WOULD LISTEN TO.
>> WATCH HIM ON TELEVISION.
>> HE COULD COME CLEAN.
>> IT'S NOT CONSERVATIVES.
IT'S TRUMP BACKERS BECAUSE OF
THE MAGA HAT?
>> NO, NO.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> I DON'T THINK IT'S
CONSERVATIVES.
>> YOU ARE MISSING MY POINT.
A CHANCE FOR A GUY TO DO
SOMETHING RIGHT.
>> THIS THING IS SO CONFUSING.
IT'S A BIG MESS IN MY MIND.
I WILL SAY THIS, I THINK THE GUY
LIED.
I DON'T THINK THERE IS MUCH
DOUBT ABOUT IT.
I WAS SURPRISED THIS MORNING
BECAUSE I DIDN'T THINK THERE WAS
MUCH NEWS HERE.
COPS SEE THINGS DIFFERENTLY THAN
PROSECUTORS.
COPS THINK HE LIED AS I DO.
THE PROSECUTOR SAID THIS IS NOT
WORTH THE TIME, THE MONEY AND
THE EFFORT TO PROSECUTE THIS
GUY.
HE IS SOME BIG STAR.
UNLIKELY DO  TO DO THIS AGAIN.
LET'S MAKE A DEAL AND GET OUT OF
HERE.
SOME PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO LET IT
GO.
>> WE DIDN'T KNOW HE HAD A
PREVIOUS CONVICTION.
>> SURE WE DID.
>> NO, WE DIDN'T WE DIDN'T THINK
THERE WAS A DRUG CONNECTION
BETWEEN HIM AND THE BROTHERS.
>> COME ON.
>> ONLY THROUGH LEAKS.
OFFERED TO PICK THESE TWO OUT OF
THE LINE-UP AND REFUSED AND THE
SWEETHEART DEAL WAS IN THE
PROCESS FROM EARLIER THAN WE
THOUGHT.
IT WAS CROOKED FROM THE JUMP.
WE DODGED A RACE WAR.
IF YOU SAW 2 GUYS IN MAGA HATS
BEATING A CELEBRITY GAY ACTOR,
THIS WOULD HAVE BEEN VIOLENCE
ACROSS THE COUNTRY BECAUSE OF
THIS HOAX.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
GLNCH [INAUDIBLE].
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].JGLNCH[
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].JGLNCHN
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].JGLNCHU
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].JGLNCHI
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].JGLNCHL
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].JGLNCH]
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].JGLNCH.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].GLNCH I
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].GLNCH A
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].GLNCH D
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].GLNCH B
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].GLNCH E
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].GLNCH .
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING]... [INU
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING]... [INI
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING]... [INL
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING]... [IN]
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING]... [IN.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].>> [INU
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].>> [INI
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].>> [INL
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].>> [IN]
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> I NEVER HEARD OF THE GUY
BEFORE THIS.
>> LET'S REMEMBER THAT
CELEBRITIES CAME OUT IN SUPPORT
OF HIM, MANY DID.
IT WAS A CAUSE CELEB.
IT WAS VERY EMBARRASSING FOR ALL
OF THEM WHEN SUDDENLY THE STORY
IS NOT WHAT EVERYBODY THOUGHT IT
WAS.
HE DID HIGH-PROFILE INTERVIEWS
WITH ROBIN ROBERTS AND WORKED UP
ABOUT THESE GUYS.
HE SAID I WANT THAT VIDEO FOUND
SO EVERYONE WILL STOP SAYING
THIS IS AN ALLEGED ATTACK.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> I THINK THE COLOR IS
IRRELEVANT.
>> OH, COME ON, THIS IS ABOUT
WHAT GREG SAID.
>> IT'S ABOUT RIGHT AND WRONG.
YOU DON'T MAKEUP STUFF.
>> OH, COME ON!
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> THE POLICE CHIEF RAN IN FRONT
OF THE BUS WITH THE MAYOR AND
SAID WE KNOW THIS AND THAT.
THEY SHOULD HAVE WAITED.
>> LIKE MUELLER.
>> HE SMEARED THE POLICE AND THE
BROTHERS.
NOW THE CITY IS OUT THE MONEY
FOR THE INVESTIGATIONS THAT WENT
FORWARD.
HE GOT AWAY WITH ONLY PAYING
$10,000.
IF HE KEPT HIS MOUTH SHUT, HIS
SHOW MIGHT STILL BE GOING ON.
ALL OF THE ACTORS WANTED IT TO
CONTINUE BUT THEY COULD DO NOT
THAT.
THE BROTHERS ARE HAVING TO SUE
HIM AND SMOLLETT'S LAWYERS
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T MAKE A
LIVING.
THERE IS A TRAIL OF DESTRUCTION
BEHIND THIS GUY.
>> THE BROTHERS CAN COME TO